Real estate in Orange County
is better than it's ever been.
I've hit the $100-million sales
milestone, which is a big deal.
Ring it hard.
Big announcement.
In Cabo San Lucas, we have
our first billion-dollar listing.
-Billion? Like, with the "B"?
-Yeah, let's all get rich.
-This is the vibe.
-Cheers.
You guys are here
before the LA office.
This is what I'm talking about.
Let the race begin.
Get a bucket.
People are thinking
that we're messy as a brokerage.
Everybody in OC's talking about it.
What's the latest
with you and Rose?
She's unprofessional.
-Are you single?
-Yeah.
People can think
whatever they want to think.
Let's remember,
this is a small town.
Reputations matter.
I think you guys are too friendly.
It looks sloppy.
I don't give a--
Remind me never to piss you off.
We have a new agent.
She'll ruffle a few feathers.
She's pretty, charismatic,
but overrated.
You think everything's so easy.
She's Jarvis 2.0.
-To taking over OC.
-I love it.
The numbers here
just blow my mind.
It is our biggest listing ever.
Thirty-nine million.
You went to my client
behind my back.
There's a lot of hypocrisy.
-You don't know my personal life.
I want you to stop talking about me.
You have been showing people
a video of me and Tyler.
-Really?
-Is there a video?
-Did you see a video?
-Shots are fired.
It's time for it to go down.
What advice do you have?
Choose a different career.